and so yes and thank you very much as I
said my name's Dan Wheldon and we're
going to be talking about - and/or
interactive data visualizations without
JavaScript and all kind of an
alternative title for this presentation
I think would be so what you can can
should and also probably shouldn't and
do with that which is a library from
floppy and so of course this talk I want
to kind of explore a little bit about
why you might want to use - and then
kind of give a very basic introduction
to it not a in-depth sort of deep dive
tutorial because obviously that's what
the documentation is for and but I do
want to also discuss a bit or it kind of
provides some introductory examples and
then discuss some of the things that
we've learned and at my company decision
lab from using that across different
teams and also if you're interested in
some other points that I kind of talk
about later on and you don't want to get
more involved in - or have any kind of
advice or and interesting points to
discuss please do come and approach me
I'll be at the conference today and also
at the the drinks this evening and I
should also just before we continue out
a very quick disclaimer and that
disclaimer is that you know I'm not an
expert on the - project I'm not an
author and in this particular library or
anything like that this really is to
talk about my personal experience and
the experience of my company using -
rather than kind of a a sales pitch for
it from the open source community and so
you might ask if I'm not an expert why
am I here and also more to the point I
mean my background is as a full-stack
developer I'm a JavaScript developer I
work in - and for my sins I used to work
in PHP as well and it's a bit weird to
be using javascript there so to be using
Python to write JavaScript and and so
kind of I want to explain how it is that
I kind of came to be using - on a
regular basis at work and so I work for
this company and decision love we're a
mathematical modeling consultancy based
in central London in the UK and I should
just say very quickly before we carry on
if you are following the latest in the
brexit
Arkel I'm sorry and it's I haven't got a
clue what's going on either and it
really is not good but it's lovely I
should say want to say thank you to the
organizers of this conference and so
everyone who's come here from all over
Europe and events like this across
different countries and within the whole
of Europe are really quite special and
so more of this less of that please
anyway and so decision now we are as a
as I said a mathematical modeling
consultancy we have expertise in machine
learning and a data science optimization
and simulation we work mostly in defense
and engineering intelligence public
bodies various other kind of different
markets and our kind of we're a small
company and our primary interest is in
unusual bits of data interesting
problems and things that we haven't
necessarily done before so one of our
kind of main selling points as well is
that we don't just take someone's data
and write a report we build tools using
data and some of these tools for example
this was a project recently where we and
took satellite imagery and then analyzed
it to look for deforestation to detect
illegal gold mining in the Amazonian
rainforest providing tools to the
Colombian government and at the moment
we're also deploying onboard these
things here this is our deployment
environment forget AWS forget azure and
we're deploying on a type 45 destroyer
for the Royal Navy and with a predictive
maintenance system based on then you're
add neuron network machine learning and
but so obviously we're a company of data
scientists and people like myself
software engineers as well but one of
the kind of problems or there are things
that we noticed is definitely this kind
of two cultures to python
I'm sure you in fact it's evident in
this this conference today this is a
joint conference between Python Germany
and PI later Berlin you can see this is
a sort of like data scientist sort of
ecosystem in Python and there's also the
kind of software engineer sort of
ecosystem maybe focusing on the web or
sort of and microplace than other kind
of frameworks and so it's not quite as
bad as the kind of CF snow sa with the
two cultures and the arts and humanities
back in the 1950s and so on but there is
definitely in my opinion that kind of
you know those sort of two cultures and
two sort of backgrounds
see your typical person working in
Python and they have different
priorities and different approaches say
and it's really important that the these
two kind of communities collaborate with
one another I mean hence why everyone's
here today right and but generally if
you're working to a deadline and there's
something on on something that might be
commercially sensitive as well you
actually kind of want to minimize often
the number of new technologies that say
a data scientist has to learn or this
might be someone who's just you know
recently joined a company or just like
fresh out of their PhD or something you
want to minimize the new like non data
technologies that they need to learn in
order to be able to take a project on
because I really want my data scientists
to be taking a lead developing like a
proof of concept or an hour for talking
to a client and you know doing
interesting things with data but their
background probably is an in web
development and it's probably not really
what excites them or what they kind of
like come into work for in the morning
so that's how we just cover - and this
the project sorry plotly and and the
kind of the selling point is that this
is a team of data scientists or people
who make data science tools and allow
you to build websites and using pure
Python and not having to learn
JavaScript it's an open source project
and there are some paid kind of
consultancy options as well that you can
use and it recently is quite a young
project but it did recently hit version
one I think in June and which there was
a big deal in the kind of - community
say and the kind of selling point of -
might have said is that it allows you to
build an interactive website without
having to use JavaScript and that's a
good thing sometimes but not not always
and so in the rest of this talk where I
want to go for is just explain how -
works and fundamentally what it does
give some examples of what you can do
really quickly with that and also some
discussed some of it kind of like I said
before the tips and good practices that
we've kind of learned as a company but
I'll also cover this point here which is
when you want to stop using - and build
a more involved or like a you know a
proper sort of website and some of the
kind of considerations that you might
want to think about when you're deciding
to start a project in - and so first
things first if install bash it's very
very straightforward you can
simply install it by app it and then use
it as a standard kind of Python Python
script hello world example is up here
say if we have a look here we're
importing these two libraries - and -
HTML components which I'll discuss in a
second you create an app just like you
might do if you're familiar with flask
and actually under the hood - here is
creating a flask application for you
you define a layout and so here we've
got a very simple layout just one div
for division tag and then we've got a
heading tag in there as well which is
just have some text in it and then we
literally just run that script or burn
that server and now this is where I have
to think about across different web
browsers I'm afraid but if you bear with
me you can see very very simply that we
have created a application this
equivalent of our hello world and that
is actually generated using that that
code and I've put a little logo on there
using some fancy CSS because there's a
default that would look for a CSS file
for you by default and we've got it
running up on my laptop now I'm actually
there is a doc sorry a github repository
on my github so I'm just go to github
done well done and you can find these
repositories that have all of the code
examples that I'm using today plus some
more and you can run them in a little
docker container and it just opens up
all the different examples on different
ports so that's our hello world and
sorry I'm gonna have to squeeze this
over here and then point and say hello
well but that's not an interactive web
page is it and but we'll come to exactly
how to make it interactive in just a
moment and under the hood or what that
is doing for us and is basically just
two libraries that talk to one another
and so one of those libraries is this
HTML components which we imported up at
the top before and that is just a
wrapper around lots of different
reactive components which we'll come to
in a second so this is just a Python
wrapper around a react component which
itself is wrapping an HTML tag and so
this library allows us to kind of define
HTML layouts using just Python and then
there's an actual application which
manages the relationships between these
particular components and it serves the
application for us locally or on our
server wherever we want using flask like
I said before though the hello world
scripts are just you know display some
HTML for us isn't particularly
interesting we want to have interactive
web pages that allow our users to kind
of do something a bit beyond reading
just some text and so how before I
explain how this works and show an
example in in - I thought it'd probably
be quite useful especially for people
who might not have a background in web
development and to explain how this
would work in plain old JavaScript so um
first off we're going to have to define
a layout and write some HTML and here we
create some Dom nodes and I should say
as well just at the top here this isn't
Dom as in me I'm a web developer that
happens to be called Dom DOM actually
stands for the document object model so
this isn't vanity when I start talking
about the Dom this is just the the lingo
I'm afraid and so we create these three
Dada Dom nodes up here and as you can
see we've got this paragraph tag this
spam and this input and the way that we
kind of represent this as a tree is here
we've just got a paragraph and then the
span you can see that that's there the
span with a particular ID that's donated
by that that hashtag layer and likewise
the input there that's denoted by that
ID and basically all I want to do is
create a script that rather than saying
hello world or hello Berlin whatever
allows a user to type their name in and
it will say hello to that particular
user and so what I need to do is take
the value that's put into that input so
that's the text fields there and then
set it is the HTML that's going to be
inside of my span and but rather than
doing that just once when the page loads
a I need to write a JavaScript
application that's going to do that
continually and so whenever it changes
it's going to update the Dom and do
something and to make sure that the page
is up-to-date and so
the technologies that are involved here
the main one is JavaScript which allows
us to manipulate me or manipulate the
DOM and then react which is a JavaScript
library that allows us to rather than
write a full JavaScript application and
code in pure JavaScript and implement
everything ourselves react allows us to
do this declaratively so we just define
what we want to happen and then react
takes care of the rest for us and so
ultimately and the piece of code which
is going to say hello to our particular
user and display it in the front end and
put it in that spam and is going to be a
bit a Java Script that looks something
like this
the exact syntax here isn't isn't
especially important but the important
point is that there's going to be some
JavaScript that runs inside a user's
browser that updates the Dom for us and
kind of implements the behavior that we
want meanwhile though we start looking
at how to do this inside of - that is a
Python library and all of the logic that
we write and all of the code that comes
to - or that you put in - is Python code
and so the interactions between our
different Dom elements or the different
and the different - components that we
put into an inside of our app are going
to be written in Python and that Python
is going to live on our server and so
that means that every time any input
changes or we'd have any kind of
interactivity on on the front end of our
website we're going to have to make a
call back to the server and where our
Python script lives and run something
there so we're constantly crossing a
network to have these sort of
interactive web pages and so if we take
a very brief example here we rewrite to
the JavaScript app that we've just
discussed and we put it into - here so
you can see I'm just defining that
layout again using the HTML components
and if the input component those so
that's our text box is actually and
belongs to a third library called - core
components that we have to import as
well and so we've got our input here and
then I'm creating this callback and
that's literally just a Python callable
and so usually a function and I'm
defining and the
that's and the input to this function so
whenever any of these inputs changed and
this function is going to be called and
it's going to create some output here
and the output of this particular
function so while it's returning in this
case a string it's going to come and
live inside of this h1 app it and it's
gonna as I say it's gonna run anytime
that this particular input here changes
so it's a little bit like an excel field
or something where you kind of you know
you're making a reference to some other
cell and whenever you update that cell
letting other cells related to it in
there in the kind of the formula I kind
of updates as well and so now if we know
if you'd let me pull this wherever I'm
afraid and we now go to our second
example and so here you can see we've
I'm running this locally now I've set up
this sort of an interactive example and
now if I want to I'm dropping that
pointer I could type star six and you
can see that here that has created an
interactive web page for us we've
written everything using Python there's
no JavaScript at all that we've suddenly
got an interactive web page that we can
start to play with so this is Google
slides never ever Snickers um and say as
I said before every change they that's
gonna happen on that website every time
I push the key on my laptop just then T
were to change the and the text that's
in that heading and my browser made a
call to the server which in this case is
also on my laptop but if it was on the
internet it would be over over again
Network for example and to run that
piece of Python that's just that very
basic link interpolation there and using
the kind of F string syntax that was new
in three point six and and this causes a
huge sort of performance loss and
actually say in Berlin I'm not sure that
this really carries much weight anymore
because I've tried one of those and
electric scooters last night and they're
really really powerful
especially yes I'm not sure which is
which is reacting which is which is
Daffy here but and there's a huge
performance loss in terms of the kind of
interactivity of your webpage but that's
generally okay
and you know I'm building really basic
sort of proof-of-concept app here I want
it to be made by a data scientist and
it's not going to be a huge production
load application and it might be for you
know 10 20 100 users and kind of
specialist area and people who are
looking at in their particular data sets
or wants to have some results from a
machine learning model say it doesn't
have to be super super performant and in
the way that you know Airbnb say it
might be and so it's good and my data
scientists can take the lead and you
know really start to build things with
it and so if you want to think about
what can you actually do in that how far
can you go well the answer is very far
actually and I mean the data so I could
say in the and in its name is geared
towards building dashboards above
anything else but you can actually have
some really quite interesting sort of
transactional kind of activities or
build transactional webpages and which
I'll show in a minute as well and so
just give a very brief whirlwind tour of
some of the different different
functions of - and features of what you
can do I'm gonna show you three examples
one is going to be listing essentially a
data frame but making it interactive
another one is going to display a graph
and because obviously plotly a very
well-known for plotting and then thirdly
we're gonna just explain what I mean by
this kind of transactional and
approachable transactional request
before and I can say all of the examples
are in this this github repository here
so if you want to take a look in more
detail then head over there so first off
the displaying a data frame I took the
Titanic data set so this is the list of
all of the passengers on the Titanic and
you can see here and this might look
like quite a lot of code but actually
it's just a lot of it's the way it's
formatted so we have this data table
here as you can see and then I've
created this drop-down as well so this
is just my layout I've got a data table
and drop-down
and I've got this callback which just
filters my the data that goes into my
data table based on the value of that
particular drop-down and so now if we
come back to a previous example you can
see here I've got the data set that is
in my data frame and this is all using
Python there's no JavaScript involved
here and if I wanted to show just the
female passengers thoughts unsex you can
see here I've got a list of just the
female passengers running male and then
likewise for indicator or sex it is you
can see I can update that and all of
this is happening just in Python there's
no JavaScript involved here no one's had
to learn any new front-end technologies
and you could do this in a G Python
notebook if you wanted to there's no
kind of special web thing here it's just
the data data science library and so if
I just move this back
so moving on that and so you can see
here this this callback with the
decorator that's what makes it
interactive a graph that's and often one
of the things that we really need to
present no data science report some kind
and and again it might look like a lot
of code but again it's how it's
formatted and there's this data core
component and they actually have lots of
different types of graph built in in
this case I'm just building a histogram
I've split up my data set so I'm
displaying the number of or the
frequency of passengers on board the
Titanic by the first letter of their
first name which was a fun little this
comprehension to write if you look
inside of that that github repository
and so here I'm literally just defining
I'm gonna have a graph here's my data
putting some labels on and all that kind
of thing and then again I hit run and
again you could do this in a energy
price a notebook really quite easily and
you can see I've got a webpage now with
a full you know histogram just as paid
using pure Python and I could make that
interactive and I could put all sorts of
other you know different interactions
and can build up a lot of complexity and
marry at exact location on my
application
and then finally this transactional
example and this is something that I
think is really powerful if you start
using - a lot inside of your company
because rather than just displaying
information like in the web page often
you want to have the ability to change
that information may be to leave a
comment or two and actually classify
images so you want to say yes or no is
this an example of deforestation or not
and so here I'm creating a very classic
web development tutorial which is a
to-do list
so here I've just got an unordered list
that I'm going to populate with my tasks
I've got this input which is gonna take
some text from the user and I've got a
button here and so that every time that
buttons clicked I want to do something
and say then I define a callback
actually well here I'm mimicking having
a database say so in this example I just
literally put a list inside of memory
and I've got this this function that
will give me a list of list items here
so this is an HTML tag and then this
callback again the important thing here
is that and wherever that buttons
clicked and so buttons have a property
which is the number of times that been
clicked so whenever that goes up this
code here is going to run and I'm
pulling out the value from my from my
inputs in my text field and then I'm
able to add that or append that to my
list of tasks and so again now if I move
this over there you can do list to do
this so we could add any that we want in
here and we've created a very basic
to-do application there and the
important thing is that okay this is
loaded inside of memory but if I was to
refresh the page now for example and
it's still there because I'm having to
shut down my server and you can put that
into a database like a MongoDB or a
sequel database or something like that
and you can actually start to create
interactive tools where you don't just
display data but you actually you're
able to edit this as well and also make
changes to your state
you can also build your own data
components and so if you are a
JavaScript developer or you have one on
your team and you want to extend the
functionality of - in a particular
direction that isn't covered yet you can
create your own your own components and
use it however you want and that as a
slight criticism of that I would say
that the actual API here is slightly
limited and that access to some advanced
JavaScript features like being able to
use redux for example is complicated at
best sometimes I'm sorry but that being
said you can actually go very very far
with that and we're example from a
project we use recently and this is
actually a slightly older this iteration
of this project but this is a machine
learning and tool so in the back end
here there's a whole machine learning
pipeline that takes images from
satellites and look at the deforestation
and then decides on each instance of the
deforestation how likely is it that it's
down to illegal mining and which there
we're trying to detect for the Colombian
government and this is a tool that's
used by law enforcement kind of upon a
trial basis for a particular algorithm
and you can see we've got all sorts of
thresholds and filters and they can
approve or and they just a proof or
inject particular hypotheses and so on
and and yeah it's not this isn't my case
really slip sort of web application
necessarily like a Facebook or a Google
or something and but it was built by two
data scientists with no web experience
over the course of a couple of months as
they were iterating on their model and
so when we want to kind of take this
further and actually take it out to
another TRL or you know kind of deploy
it as a bigger tool will obviously
change this around but in order for
rapid prototyping on small teams this
was the brilliant project for us being
that we were really able to advance
things very very quickly here and the
only slightly complicated part of of
this was the the mapping component here
and which we built in-house and looking
to open-source as well um so just some
final like passing tips for when you
start to build Marja - applications and
the tips are really the same as building
any larger software project or larger
data science project and that is to kind
of religiously organize your code
and you know spit your callbacks and
your layouts in two different files say
and start to run things as modules and
really kind of think about the logic and
the organization of your code
so a typical - example we have here in
this this isn't covered in the
documentation but more of a convention
that we developed a decision that we'll
have for every particular component or
layout or route that we build inside of
- and we have the call backs our layouts
file and then these are kind of
hierarchical and nested and we've also
begun developing a internal framework
for - and so moving away from just
writing single - scripts than to
actually kind of declaratively and
defining our roots and our particular
end points and - and the core levels
that we want to use and that allows us
to for example automate loading data
frames and implement things like
dependency injections so if you want a
connection to a database we provide the
data scientist with the connection to
the database rather than have to worry
about connection strings and secret
handling and all that kind of thing and
inside of a data science project and so
if this is something that you think
might be interesting then please let us
know because we are looking to open
sources in the future and we are always
looking for volunteers to kind of help
and provide details to that particular
framework and that just before we finish
and I think the really important thing
to and discuss is actually when you want
to stop using - and start building like
a more advanced or a more involved these
inverted commas here proper web
application and so just to kind of
summarize - is really good for a rapid
UI development by non-specialists data
scientists can get an application up and
running without specialist knowledge
really really quickly and the
applications they build are actually
very informed as well and you know they
don't hand over work to say I software
engineer or a front-end developer who
doesn't necessarily kind of it isn't as
interested in the data science aspect as
they are in the trend of the UI
development aspect but at the same time
- this presents quite a few problems
because it's really rapid UI development
by non-specialists and so if you're
gonna start a project that you think
might eventually lead to building a
production
application maybe you should get a
JavaScript engineer on board really
quickly because otherwise you're going
to create some technical debt if you're
eventually going to have to build
something in JavaScript sometimes biting
the bullet is better than you know
continuing down the line and and
likewise this infor idea that UI
development is informed well you have to
ask who's informing it and you know it
might be a very informed by a data
scientist but actually we do not be
better doing a lot of user research here
and getting some UX consultants in to
see what's the tool that you actually
want to build and how how are your users
going to be using it in the end
and also what you can do in - using
these components is of course somewhat
limited as well so it's actually a great
tool for facilitating rapid development
and especially with laser driven
dashboard interfaces and so on and
actually investing a little bit of time
into it and getting onboard with it as a
company say really can you know allow
you to go very very far and produce some
really cool tools and but I'd say the
take-home messages that actually front
end developers will still have a job
that's just not here to replace so
thanks very much
[Applause]
thank you very much maybe we have time
for one or two questions so thank you
for your talk I'm using - myself at work
and as one question is do you have any
experience with custom design I think
you mentioned quickly CSS but maybe you
have a bootstrap template or something
you want to apply have you worked with
that and what is your experience
yes PD say as an example actually of the
this isn't really the design and that's
example of how we kind of these are
internal sort of framework and often you
find that you don't want to have a -
application that has just one graph or
one display or something like that and
say and we try and take the design
decisions away from and the people doing
the data science as much as possible in
style everything using kind of
consistent CSS and but one of the good
things that we well good practices we
retry and develop is because we have
them we have a framework that
essentially you usually a decorator say
this is my layout this is my callback
and then we kind of assemble a data
application under the hood and it means
that we can actually do things like
implementing routing and navigation and
that kind of stuff and without the
designers having to worry about that and
say hey for example I've got the same
component repeated twice and that's
being built oh he says and that yeah
yeah and there's kind of being repeated
twice and handle by by our framework and
then we have internal CSS tooling that
are like I'm gonna crates
banners and sort of corporate identity
since - so um so yeah none of it was the
SS but also abstract out your your
scripts I would say to make it more
appeasable and we're using a DES as well
you have talked about rapid development
you have any experience using this in a
more production environment I mean we've
had quite a few problems with flash
being embedded in - and not the other
way around especially around deployment
is that something you can comment about
yes it can be a real pain for example if
you want to have an AP
plus a user interface and maybe some
swagger documentation or living on the
same flask application and it yeah it is
a real pain and the way you be kind of
solve that is that we don't and we
wouldn't necessarily use bash in
something that we would consider to be
like a proper production environment say
aboard like a you know destroyer or
something and we really keep this to
like our proof of concepts and kind of
our alphas and as a development tool and
then it's we want to build something
that's a bit bigger or more involved and
we have kind of front-end engineers that
would start to take that over so and so
yeah we use this for rapid templating
and prototyping and so did you know
building and proof of concepts alphas
and rather than meters or actual kind of
proper products that we would deploy
yeah I thank you very much it was very
insightful unfortunately we don't have
time for questions any more so please
feel free to approach though maybe here
or in the foyer later let's give an
applause to our speakers